you're watching sky news at four o'clock
and we start this hour with breaking
news the release of a damning report
into british gymnastics and the abuse of
young children the report exposes a
brutal culture inside the sport with
young gymnasts starved and forced to go
through humiliating punishments
the review examined hundreds of
complaints between 2008 and 2020 to
uncover the regime imposed by some
coaches and it says that countless young
people were shamed and permanently
damaged both physically and
psychologically
well the review by mary white qc covered
a 12-year period during which british
gymnastics was estimated to have
received 3500 complaints the majority of
its members during that period were
children under the age of 12.
the white review published today
examined 400 complaints and said an
unacceptable culture within british
gymnastics left countless people
humiliated shamed and damaged by their
time in the sport
67 percent of those spoke of emotional
abuse 49 of physical abuse and nine
percent of sexual abuse
more than a quarter of submissions
reported excessive weight management as
a particular form of abusive behavior
well our sports correspondent tom
parmenter has more on this breaking news
so tom as we say a really damning
verdict on some of the experiences that
these young gymnasts
had during these years
it is a quite breathtaking report
actually having read it over the last
few hours and only now can we report the
full details of what the right white
review lays out and it is a catalogue of
abuse both emotional and physical abuse
within british gymnastics that really
just
astonishes anyone i think who reads it
it shows quite graphically stories from
gyms from around the united kingdom of
children being abused as part of their
sports of them being punished for being
late punishments which would include
being made to hang from the rings inside
a gymnasium or one youngster who was
forced to balance on a beam for two
hours as part of a punishment for being
late the culture within british
gymnastics that is laid bare has been
talked about for some time but to have
it all collated into one place is a
damning indictment of those coaches
involved not every coach within
gymnastics of course but those coaches
that have been involved in this abuse uh
really
it is
something that beggars belief just what
children have been put through in the
name of sports and british gymnastics
the organization the governing body who
are supposed to have oversight on all
this are singled out for
damning criticism that says that there
was just a culture of silence a culture
of just accepting that these things were
the norm and a culture in which
complaints if they were raised and many
didn't even feel able to raise them such
was the relationship between some
coaches and athletes that if those
complaints did make it any further there
wasn't a culture of investigating those
things properly
the numbers involved are some 400 people
who have given evidence to the white
review but in reality there are many
many other youngsters predominantly
girls who have gone through the
gymnastic system over the last couple of
decades who report similar uh
accusations of bullying of body shaming
of being made to feel just worthless as
part of their sport of being
punished as we say but also starving
themselves in the name of sport such was
the culture around body image and weight
that the scales of tyranny was one of
the phrases that was used in the way
that coaches would do daily weigh-ins
for gymnasts and publicly
name the figures that they were reaching
in their body weights and the corrosive
effect of all that on young people and
their aspirations uh is just
extraordinary we've been speaking to
many gymnasts who have been through
horrific experiences in their early
lives that have in some cases destroyed
childhoods and have long lasting
legacies we've also spoken to
jennifer jennifer mcilveen who
is from a body called gymnast for change
who have campaigned to raise the profile
of this abuse going on within british
gymnastics and she told us that what
we've seen outlined today is a
vindication of all those athletes who
have come forward and shared their
experiences and also it's the moment for
change
it's absolutely child abuse i've seen
comments online people saying oh they're
just not tough enough they don't
understand what it takes to be an elite
athlete it's absolutely uncalled for as
you can see from the testimonials in
this report we're talking about serious
physical in 40 of the cases in the white
review physical abuse emotional
psychological abuse that leads to
serious trauma eating disorders and ptsd
and in some cases sexual abuse this is
not tough coaching this is an epidemic
of abuse that we're talking about
so this damning report what's the
response been what are the sporting
bodies saying about it
well at the heart of this particular
shaming report within sport a young
people because the vast majority of
those athletes involved are children
and the governing bodies have a lot of
very difficult questions to deal with
and we've been putting some of those to
uk sport who have oversight of this but
also more pointedly to british
gymnastics the governing body who are
singled out as an insular organization
who have just failed to appreciate the
scale and culture that has been going on
within their sport and the report
outlines a disconnect between the
governing body and those within the
community of gymnastics in the uk we
spoke earlier to the new chief executive
of british british gymnastics sarah
powell who told us that she is truly
sorry for what
many many athletes have had to
experience at the hands of abusive
coaches over the years and that she is
determined to ensure that the
organization puts things right so that
children their families can have faith
and confidence that when they go to a
british gymnastics gym or event that
they are in a safe environment
my overall riding response is one of
emotion and
it was not
good reading and it was quite harrowing
and emotional
sports been so important to me
throughout my life and to see that the
experiences of those gymnasts has not
been a positive one
is heart-wrenching um and we clearly
haven't put the welfare of gymnasts at
the heart of what we do at british
gymnastics
so the governing body is certainly in no
doubt as to the scale of the challenge
that they now face to rebuild trust with
athletes and to try to put right some of
the wrongs of the past to ensure that
the horrific experiences that so many
particularly young girls have gone
through through gymnastics
really is never allowed to be repeated
but significantly uh we put to the uh
chief executive that
not many coaches have actually been
sanctioned and some indeed are still
working within the sport and she says
that that is a situation that cannot
allow be allowed to continue they have
to be evidence-based in the
investigations and decisions that they
take but they acknowledge that
punishments should follow and
potentially bans or significant fines
for the behavior of the past but she
said this is about creating a better
path for the future to ensure that
people do have confidence in the way
that british gymnastics is operating and
that those good coaches out there have
the vindication that they have a
governing body that is operating in the
right way that is fit for a modern
society because quite simply what we've
uncovered or seen uncovered in this
report is that british gymnastics was
not fit for purpose and that abusive
coaches were getting away with the
physical and emotional abuse of
youngsters to the detriment of so many
lives and today in many ways is a
testament to the way that so many of
them have decided to come forward and
speak about their experiences often
deeply personal traumatic episodes that
have had long lasting effects on
gymnasts even when they've left the
sport of gymnastics and today is that
moment of change they hope for their
sport a sport that of course so many
people love and participate in but that
context and framework around it has
failed for so for too long and now the
challenge for the sporting authorities
is that that needs to change and one
footnote to that is that the report
calls for a sport ombudsman that would
be a regulator a independent
body that would allow people to approach
a body that they trust with complaints
and for those complaints to be looked at
independently and fairly uh that will of
course need a response from the uk
government but stinging criticism today
for the sport of gymnastics and more
widely i think across the world of sport
a big wake-up call to the
culture that has been allowed to fester
within gymnastics and what that means
around safeguarding the protection of
young athletes particularly going
forward